dann wenn ich also noch mal auf kanal
gegangen aufgefallen und zwar es geld
solltest du dich bei dem gedanken dass
von heute ist eine sache die mich
persönlich trifft ich bin einfach immer
leute okay dass man morgens aus dem haus
geht und über seine eigenen füße
stolpern gibt es auf jeden fall erstmal
eine anlage mit kate zu kommen zu einem
neuen video seht schon im hintergrund
das setting hier ist bisher an ich bin
darüber netzwerk in berlin ich habe auch
momentan recht wenig zeit die ganze
termine habe aber ich geb wieder
brandheiße neuigkeiten direkt aus den
fraglichen youtube bereich von
promiflash und zwar wieder gefragt was
ich machen sollte und der beiden mega
viele von euch logica und sympathisch
hat ein video fertig gemacht und das ist
natürlich immer der sommer in dem video
auch nicht eingegangen worauf ich dann
selbstständig eine anlage macht jetzt
hat er am sonntag erneut video gemacht
dass wir gegen fünf minuten lang für
diese fünf minuten hat er drei minuten
für mich geredet und ich glaub sascha
ist daun mit dem sie zu langsam
ich habe mich mal wieder gegeben in die
rtl weiß so richtig köln 50 847 des
youtube soll wieder auf mein liebling
gestoßen
[Musik]
irgendwas hat fleischer es gibt so viele
youtuber in deutschland je 400.000 autos
haben es gibt so viele menschen darauf
über die man sich machen könnte aber
sascha hat sich scheinbar auch nicht
eingeschlossen und zeigten ausschnitte
aus meinem video und bezeichnung mit dem
wunsch ein dickes youtuber sagen dass
ich nicht denn die partitur bin oder
nicht hoch nehmen leute ein video eine
anlage uns vorgemacht und wie wir alle
wissen es ja ich will mich doch das ist
nicht der uni oder sarkasmus das ist
alles das ist in dem video von mir der
anlage angebracht programm bekam eine
stelle vor in dem video auf die
möglichen fitnessübungen ja also wie
gesagt es ist einfach übung daher lässt
und seinen oberkörper runter und
trainiert hat betrieb setzte anfangs von
dem gesicht erkennen kann wie breit
jemand ist dann bin ich aber auf apps
kanal gegangen ist das aufgefallen und
zwar bei ihm bedanken
ich meine jetzt gucken wir am ersten
reaktionen auf die waf hoffnung für
danke baby bestimmen die clubmusik 1 6
millionen auf 50 1 % der lieblings jusos
ersten zwei wochen gewarnt hat sascha
mit rtl2 niveau weil ich selbst auch den
rtl2 leichter leben gemacht habe ich
studiert habe mich war zeitig habe dann
zurück ist geliebt zu werden der das
ironisch gegen mich persönlich zu machen
ist einfach unter aller sau ich kann es
auch gar nicht mehr so mit sportlichen
es ist einfach es hat einfach purer
ernst ist man besorgt uns einem
einstellplatz video f danke baby das man
noch irgend andere youtuber der
sicherheit die wir bedankt hat und
dessen videos auch dann gebieten sind
eins zu eins wenn ein youtube mit babys
ihrem gesicht und babyartikeln ich eine
mischung aus der gemeinde vision was
macht es nichts aus und schüler ein und
nicht hektisch dem video zu viel gemacht
und eine million gemacht oder zwei einer
ich werd ich glaub da liegt die wurzel
allen übels sascha hat einfach dieser
ganze hype aufgaben zu hause auf dem
bett gelegen wie er selbst sagt und hat
einfach gesoffen eine ahnung kasten
zweiten stuttgart trinkt tanz äpfel oder
so und in diesem moment hatten die
lieblingsband einfach verpasst und
deswegen greift er mich jetzt sagen und
sagt ich mache es für eine hoch das ist
die kolonie und wahrscheinlich warum
marken die beiden immer auf ein paar von
euch mal ein bisschen spaß ist kein spaß
wird ich kenne sascha einfach schon so
lange und so gut wir sind damals auch in
stuttgart zusammen in den kindergarten
gegangen war doch noch ein kindergarten
bonn im parallel zwei kinder gegangen
damit dauert drin und dementsprechend
einfach echt eine sache die mich
emotional sehr tief in meinem herzen
dass er jetzt quasi schon wieder eine
art ansage nicht was zu den großteil
seines videos und mich dafür streitet
wird dass ich ein baby hat mitgenommen
habe was einfach so ganz youtube
deutschland gemacht hat und ich muss
sagen ich hab manchmal einfach mal der
boxsack wie
weil ich von youtube eigentlich nur von
sascha hellinger ich bin einfach immer
allein zurück leute okay wenn das schon
morgens das haus geht und über seine
eigenen füße stolpern gibt auf jeden
fall erstmal eine anlage skaten im
nächsten video oder wenn ich dann doch
mal ins fitnessstudio verehrt und weil
es mit der fünf kilo handel an der
beatles komplett durch reicht ist es
auch klar gegen wir die anlage am
nächsten tag dann gerichtet deswegen
heute dass am ende dieser absolut ernst
gemeinten und tiefstem herzen kommenden
ansage nur noch zu sagen dass ich eher
gestern 30 anwälte kontakt direkt als
wir rauskamen sonntag wird gerade
darüber sprechen wie die rechtlichen
zeit zurückdrehen können so dass sascha
hellinger nicht mit youtube anfängt um
mich nicht zu wissen und
selbstverständlich werde ich mich auch
mit albert zusammensetzen und den
gegenschlag fahren sollte